[Music]
on this Sunday night the needs of
Canada's most vulnerable during the
kovat 19 crisis new measures to help
children seniors the homeless and
victims of domestic abuse tough times
fall first and hardest on the most
vulnerable in our communities what the
government is doing to help what lies
ahead for hundreds of Canadian cruise
passengers stranded at sea with COBIT 19
on board how coping 19 could help shape
the response to the other global crisis
we've seen massive collective action
around the pandemic and pandemic
portraits of heroes the Canadian
photographers tribute to our frontline
workers
global national with Robin Gill
reporting tonight Coleen Christie who do
you think thanks for joining us the
prime minister is offering a message of
support to some of Canada's most
vulnerable people during the Cova 19
pandemic that includes children and
seniors the homeless and those who can't
stay at home because they're facing
abuse ur gender-based violence
he says his government wants to ensure
no one is left without the help they
need before we get to how he plans to
assist them let's take a look at the
state of the outbreak in this country as
it stands so far there are more than
6,000 confirmed cases of kovat 19 across
Canada Quebec is still the hardest hit
with more than 2,800 cases Ontario has
more than 1300 BC Alberta Saskatchewan
Nova Scotia and Newfoundland are among
the provinces reporting more than 100
cases none of it is the only province or
territory without a confirmed case as
all Canadians grapple with this crisis
the government will spend additional
money on assistance for children and
seniors but as abigail Beeman reports
some frontline workers at risk say they
still don't have the support they need
in Montreal day shelters are being set
up expecting to see a thousand homeless
people a day but frontline workers don't
have protective gear even though they
say they've asked for it every day for
weeks we're putting our lives at risk to
help those that are most vulnerable and
we do it lively but we would also like
to support and the vulnerable are who
the Prime Minister focused on Sunday he
reiterated his 200 million dollar
commitment for the homeless that money
is flexible and can be used for copa90
protective gear we're not going to
forget you will work with the
organizations you rely on and we'll have
your back Justin Trudeau also announced
new money 9 million dollars for United
Way to support seniors and seven and a
half million for the kids help phone
once again addressing children directly
there are people in your corner making
sure you're okay there are other
vulnerable groups who need help too one
example airline workers
staff of Ukraine's largest airline Don
protective suits but you don't see that
in Canada an internal email obtained by
Global News from one flight attendants
Union disappointed in Public Health's
recommendations says government
officials haven't got a hot clue about
what employees face infuriating to say
the least
meanwhile in an effort to help
healthcare workers bracing for a further
surge a new message from the country's
top doctor about those wanting to
isolate out-of-town urban dwellers
should avoid having to rural properties
as these places have less capacity to
manage kovat 19 and the strongest
language we've heard yet from a federal
minister about what Canada faces that we
are in a situation of war or similar to
assassination of law British Columbia
and Ontario have already taken steps to
centrally manage their supply chains
while Quebec's premier has been using
military analogies for a few days on
Sunday he urged everyone to follow the
battle plan Abigale be minute global
news Ottawa ad a reminder children in
need of support or counseling during
these troubling times can call the Kids
Help Phone 24 hours a day that phone
number is
to inform policies in the coming days
weeks and months perhaps we need to get
out into the public and do some contact
tracing with our children looking at
both how much virus they're shedding
what cut type of disease they're having
are they asymptomatic or not she says
results could change public policy on
decisions like when to reopen schools
then there are daycare centers we have
to think about child care you know the
daycare workers that would have to look
after children and then again kind of be
on the frontlines of this virus where
children might be kind of a silent
carrier and this virus in some provinces
including British Columbia daycares
remain open in most others
they're closed some are reopening for
children of essential workers on its
website the public health agency of
Canada says it's unknown what role
children play in community transmission
of kovat 19 there are growing calls to
dig deeper and find out Ross Lord glory
news Windsor Nova Scotia earlier this
week the Prime Minister announced the
government would spend 192 million
dollars on developing and producing
vaccines for kovat 19 it's the critical
solution scientists around the world are
trying to find tonight on the West block
Mike lacouture speaks with Canada's
minister of innovation science and
industry about the monumental task of
global coordination what is your
government doing to ensure that all of
the information is being shared and
everyone is working together towards
getting that vaccine
well we're engaged with the World Health
Organization they've got the goodwill of
many researchers around the world and
it's in a collective interest to work
together not only are we focusing on
vaccine development though and
antivirals but also production
capabilities within Canada as well in
case we need to quickly transition to
produce those vaccines here and we can
do so the minister said it's too
challenging to give a timeline on when a
vaccine might be available because of
the clinical trials that have to take
place first you can see the full
interview on the West blood
hosted this week by my clue Couture
that's later tonight on global the
federal government says the cruise ship
hit badly by coronavirus will be allowed
passage through the Panama Canal the
Holland America ship has 248 Canadians
on board four people have died aboard
the MS Zaandam and many others are
experiencing flu-like symptoms
passengers who are asymptomatic are
being transported onto another ship
Canada's foreign affairs minister says
the vessel is on track to transit
through the canal tonight the ship is
then expected to continue on to Fort
Lauderdale another developing story
tonight Global Affairs confirms a
Canadian was killed on a plane that
burst into flames in the Philippines it
caught fire while attempting to take off
from Manila's Airport bound for Japan
the aircraft was carrying eight people
there were no survivors airport
officials say the plane was on a medical
mission to bring a patient to Tokyo they
report a Canadian and an American
national were on board along with six
Filipinos back to our top story just one
month after the u.s. reported its first
kovat 19 death America has become the
epicenter of the pandemic the death toll
doubled in just two days in America's
top infectious disease specialists is
now warning that millions of people face
infection and 200,000 could die already
more than 100 36,000 people are infected
and more than 2,400 have died from the
virus late today President Trump sent a
warning to Americans saying the worst is
yet to come the peak the highest point
of death rates who remember this is
likely to hit in two weeks nothing would
be worse than declaring victory before
the victory is won that would be the
greatest loss of all there for the next
two weeks and during this period it's
very important that every one strongly
follow the guidelines have to follow the
guidelines the president announced today
that he is extending federal guidelines
for social distancing until April 30th
to slow the spread Jennifer Johnson has
the latest America now the world's
epicenter of the pandemic in another
attempt to contain hot spots the Centers
for Disease Control has issued a new
14-day travel advisory for people in New
York New Jersey and Connecticut the
states of more than half the country's
infections and nearly half the deaths
this is not a lockdown it is a travel
advisory it's nothing that we haven't
been doing right
non-essential people should stay at home
the travel ban does not apply to
essential industries like trucking
tighter restrictions aimed at slowing
the spread of the virus expected to only
get worse looking at what was seeing now
you know I would say between 100 and 200
thousand cases but I don't want to be
held to that because it's it's it's
excuse me deaths I mean we're gonna have
millions of cases the u.s. death toll
doubled from Thursday to Saturday as
cases the virus skyrocket in big cities
like New Orleans Milwaukee Chicago and
Detroit many governors say there is no
way things will start opening back up
around Easter time as US President
Donald Trump had suggested the
Washington Metropolitan Area has
Maryland DC and Virginia quadrupled in
the past week and we see that continuing
to grow exponentially and we think in
two weeks around Easter we're gonna be
looking a lot more like New York
hundreds on the front line are getting
infected over 500 police officers in New
York City alone
Cedric Dixon the first detective to die
from the virus we are hurting we are
crying and we continue to fight
makeshift Medical Center's are rapidly
being built by US soldiers across the
country as Koba 19 patients overwhelmed
hospitals these beds are for virus free
emergencies we want to make sure that we
can offload those patients to a hospital
setting that is going to be safe and
efficient for them with millions of
businesses shut down America's
unemployment rate continues to rise
experts say the virus could leave 20
percent of the country unemployed the
White House says it's hard to know it's
hard to predict these numbers because
we've never had anything like this where
we've shut down the US economy for
medical reasons Americans facing
uncertainty on both economic and medical
fronts as they try to survive this man
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
Italy is reporting more than 750 new
deaths today related to the pandemic
pushing the total number of fatalities
past 10,000 700 Italy accounts for more
than a third of all deaths from the
infectious virus worldwide the country's
largest daily death toll was registered
on Friday when 919 people lost their
lives
there were 889 reported on Saturday
Spain's government has moved to tighten
its lockdown measures as its death toll
rose by 838 overnight it's the country's
largest one-day rise since the outbreak
began bringing its total number of
fatalities to more than 6,600 all
non-essential workers have been ordered
to stay home for two weeks close to 79
thousand people have now tested positive
for the virus india's 21-day lockdown to
fight the pandemic is now taking a heavy
toll on its migrant workers thousands of
now unemployed workers in cities are
crowding bus stations are resorting to
hitchhiking in a mass exodus to return
home rather than face starvation the
lockdown has affected millions of
India's poor as many jobs like taxi
services and housekeeping have been
ceased un secretary-general antonio
guterres is warning of potentially
millions of deaths in africa should the
virus grow out of control in an
interview he said there was an urgent
need for more medical supplies on the
continent and called on wealthier
countries to help there are more than
4,000 cases of Coe bid 19 across Africa
with lockdowns already in effect in
South Africa Rwanda and the Democratic
Republic of Congo coming up how the
kovat 19 pandemic may impact the
environment for years to come
you
did you unplug for an hour last night it
was the 13th annual Earth Hour and more
people were certainly at home than in
past years at 8:30 local time around the
world major landmarks went dark
highlighting the need to act on the
other global crisis climate change
scientists have measured stark drops in
pollution around the world since the
kovat nineteen pandemic began measures
to curb the spread have forced huge
drops in travel and commerce globally as
the world hits pause to tackle the virus
Redman Shannon looks at how this period
could help shape environmental policies
of the future Venice is a magical place
but tourism means its canals are
normally full of traffic and polluted
that was until the pandemic stopped
everything the clear waters a glimpse
into a cleaner past the same effect can
be seen in the air northern Italy is
seeing a sharp drop this year in no.2 a
toxic pollutant from diesel vehicles a
similar effect in China across many
industries we saw operating rates that
we're about a quarter lower than you
thought that time of the year and all of
that meant that co2 emissions were
reduced by about 25 percent as China
ramps up again the annual effect may not
be huge but it is helping scientists to
see how changes in various sectors can
affect pollution and greenhouse gases
yes I think it will give us an idea of
how we're going to isolate different
processes and how much they're
contributing rushing kamon at Columbia
University in New York has measured
similar drops in pollution as the Big
Apple hibernates it was quite surprising
to see how much of the co2 dropped but
the biggest change was in the co2 carbon
monoxide
even though airlines are mothballing
their fleets and highways are empty
technology is allowing some sectors to
continue almost as normal we're at an
inflection wine and the
that we've seen massive collective
action around the pandemic and we also
have the opportunity to reset the
economy in a way that mitigates climate
change the government's could offer
incentives to employers to allow their
employees to work from home some of the
time and so that is something that we
may see come out of this lawmakers and
industry will be eager to get economies
back on their feet as soon as the
pandemic is over but they will also have
more choices in how they do so Redmon
Shannon Global News London
just ahead how to avoid some of the most
popular Kovach 19 scams
you are watching global national a
warning tonight about scammers trying to
take advantage of consumers during the
pandemic there are so many right now so
you need to protect your personal
information and your bank accounts the
Red Cross is warning Canadians about
text messages offering free face masks
saying do not click on the links
financed Canada says fraudsters are
sending text messages about receiving a
deposit from the emergency response
benefit delete the message it's a scam
even hydro-québec says scammers are
sending emails and text messages
threatening to disconnect people's power
if they don't pay their bills do not
click on the links because they often
lead to fake websites or to an interact
transfer site up next pandemic portraits
one photographers tribute to those on
the covered 19th front lines
there are a lot of people on the front
lines of the Cova 19 fight including
health care workers who put themselves
at risk when we need them the most
a Vancouver photographer wanted to show
his appreciation for their brave work so
he started a social media campaign to
tell their stories Robin Gill has more I
have never been worried or scared in my
life
as up now I'm exhausted
a lot of the work that I've been doing
is very much behind the scenes preparing
for the potential surge for enjoyment
out there we go
there health care workers overloaded by
the worst health care crisis in modern
history outside the hospital Vancouver
photographer Erik Satie is capturing the
faces of this momentous time wanting to
create more positive content for social
media a lot of the not negative but you
know just a lot of everything to do with
kovat that's out there I just saw this
need to create images and at the same
time showcase or highlight the frontline
workers sadee started the humans of
support project the photographs are
intended to show an appreciation of what
they're doing at work by profiling them
outside hospitals but also in places
where they can't be like the beach he's
not here enjoying himself why are you
and if you're here enjoying yourself a
little too much there's more of you that
are gonna be in the head into the
hospital Sadie is starting the project
with health care workers soon it'll be
flight crews doing international runs to
bring Canadians back home not to mention
the store workers providing essential
services and the list goes on his work
can be found on Instagram and the
response has been emotional I'm still
absorbing it all there right now because
it's so surreal what everyone's going
through his subjects are just just
overwhelmed by the response given the
stress they're under you're just
bombarded with doom and gloom and so
having like a beautiful little shining
light in the midst of all of that I
think it's a really really important
thing for us for morale
but there's a message behind every
photograph so I want to support and be
an advocate in providing awareness to
the community on how vital how risky how
important is what we are doing inside
the hospital so that people would take
their responsibilities more serious of
staying home it's a responsibility both
subjects and photographer are taking
seriously and hope that message
resonates with the rest of the world
with these photographs Robyn Gill Global
News Vancouver we know staying home is
critically important to our health care
workers iconic Canadian band barenaked
ladies knows how hard it is to pass the
time stuck at home so they've done
something special to brighten our
spirits we know you're getting a little
bored because we're getting a little
bored so we've come up with the selfie
cam jam we're going to leave you on this
Sunday night with a bit of that BNL
selfie cam jam along with the outpouring
of love for our health care workers and
their huge appreciation for everyone who
is helping them during this dangerous
time
[Music]
they're on the front lines of this fight
and they hear you cheering them on in
Vancouver and other cities every night
at 7 o'clock the doctors nurses and
support staff in Vancouver General
Hospital say it keeps them motivated and
inspired and they add thank you for
staying home
[Music]
[Music]